you know we're here on earth and this is
the gift is each other
you know the gift is each other
and it's been a there's been a rough
time for a lot of people you know a lot
of
you know we get addicted to the news and
addicted to the
watching the the drama and
and i was thinking the past week i've
been thinking man uh people over
politics i've been thinking
you know i care about people i don't
care i don't care i don't care about
politics
i don't it does i it just it's too much
of an argumentative space
there's no it's all it all feels like a
dirty show
you know so what can we affect what can
we be a part of that feels good is i
feel like is each other
you know i'm tired i don't need all the
extra curriculars
you know i'm just going to show up and
just feed the ducks man
you know if large east wants to be off
you know if she wants to be a large each
that's fine
i'll be a small i'm just going to try
and be a small geesh man
you know i'm going to check in with
people that i love and people that i
that that i know care about me i'm just
going to try to keep it going
but for me man i just i don't want to be
in though
i don't want to be in that hurricane man
it just i i just noticed more
i don't know man i'm not trying to
preach at you i just
you know when i look back on the past
few months
and i just feel like oh the just all the
stuff and the opini
the the stuff online and the opinions i
get and then i get angry at this person
and that
and then it's like man i'm angry i'm
getting upset with people and opinions
and stuff
of people that i care about
you know what's real here
um
so i don't know i don't know what i'm
talking about
but i'm just glad i'm not a dang
pedophile i'm glad i'm not
you know there's things to be grateful
for
and we got each other and we trying
something new
and i'm glad i don't have to try it
alone man i do two days ago i'm sitting
in here and i'm like man i'm never gonna
get this studio put together
i'm not gonna be able to figure it out
you know three days ago i was just
bombed man
and now i'm sitting here you know i'm
sitting here
we got a place they got fresh paint
you know we got another human here
you know sitting here working with you
know people from different cultures
different worlds
and it's okay you know we just keep
going man we keep going onward
i think that's it good evening good
afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah